on est chaud hier spectacle j'ai envie
de te dire on était en feu d'artifice
mais j'ai le cloud est ce qu'on va
rivaliser aujourd'hui je sais pas si tu
as vu le petit sud offs qui a écrit sur
facebook
paris l'a écrit en russe et un dd qui
fait un truc un peu à qui peut être
clivant et les clients russes on ne sait
jamais ne comprennent un ouais mais il a
dit que c'était une honte ce qui s'est
passé hier plus ou moins le même
kasparov quand il menait de deux points
ou 2 3 points contre kharkov avant la
fin de son match je pense était de match
90e mais il n'a pas joué pour l'annuler
quand tu on lui avait dit oui mais
c'était beaucoup plus intéressant et
pragmatique de faire nul
en fait je te dis non pas du tout alors
là karpov et kasparov intelligent il
s'agit en fait si je fais mieux je vais
plus rasé de fric par la suite parce que
qu'est-ce que geof comme spectacle donc
il prêt il a préféré respecter les
échecs garry à l'époque et jouer le
combat est respectée les sponsors et
respecter les échecs et tu vois comme on
dit souvent aussi gary nanani nanana
c'était un mec tu vois un peu un peu
spécial tahina il a quand même été dans
le respect des gens qui le paye et du
public non mais c'est bien mais bon du
coup pour qu'on l'a pas entendu quand
karlsson a forcé l'annulation de karaté
kid à l'époque tu t'offres qui a balancé
pas merci juste pour dire c'est ce que
dit si tu as pris bon voilà discuter de
ça et bien google à l'avant on parle pas
de casque de rapport final qu'à trois
points d'avancé bon c'est quand même
important aussi failli racheter au kenya
on s'est pas amusé vivons maxime je sais
pas je n'en sais rien à reprocher puis d
autres emboîtent qui savent pas ce
qu'ils font là alors vous restez pas par
rapport à maxime de base
non non je sais je suis enfin on parle
des quatre matches parce que je mets
toujours n'ont même pas ni en fait oui
jusqu'au 10 août au ski quoi après 8,9
ce qui suit office c'est juste pour dire
tu as il écrit pas en anglais qui ont
été chris henry schein invoqué karékine
ii lui coup on sait insipide à soi mais
déjà il est là il n'a pas annulé le
tournoi pour commencer puis il a passé
le premier tour ben tu vois je veux dire
il combat bijoux le but bon bah voilà
même moi la question que je pose la
suite offs qui déjà judy reprend la
diète
je les reprends la diète calme-toi
reprend la diète
et puisque j'ai envie de lui dire c'est
trouve nous quand même un petit peu des
sponsors
un petit peu des sponsors parce que
peut-être que le problème finalement
c'est pas les joueurs mais c'est le
format parce que tu vois tu connais
l'expression anglaise dont blame de play
off line the game ne ne blâme pas les
joueurs blame game et peut-être qu'au
final le problème c'est un petit peu la
cadence
1 parce qu'il ya un petit peu ce
problème depuis vingt ans personne s'y
intéressent a pas de sponsors et il
vient y vient tacler les joueurs j'ai
envie de lui dire calme-toi réfléchi
puis fais nous un petit peu un format
intéressant
non mais je boxe de blanc mais j'arrive
bien il fait il fait un tacle à la gorge
au joueur tu fais ce que je veux dire
bah oui on me dit qu'ils se qualifient
et je suis tranquille face au spectacle
après aussi non mais tu as savez moi je
suis un con tre tacle en fait c est toi
tu as fait un tacle par derrière moi moi
je te moi je te met les crampons sous la
gorge
alors je tiens à la cantoche quoi ouais
ouais c'est ça c'est ça ouais c'est ça
c'est que tu arrives tu arrives course
de trente mètres et boum coup de pied
dans dans la gorge quoi moi j'étais
contre tacler tu as aidé ça se réalise
il vous pensez qu ils produisent accepte
les propositions nul après huit coups
aussi donc déjà premiers tags 2d sa
sauce et gaz et violacés celle des
tacles par derrière de partout là et non
mais enfin
de toute façon même quand ils jouent
quatre heures c'est chiant aussi on est
d'accord on est bien d'accord
ça dépend des partis mais des fois des
fois souvent fois sur dix ne sais pas
mais je n'en ai bonsu tôt et nous
soutient je n'avais il vient sur
facebook qui tacle les joueurs eh ben
moi je moi moi je dis du fond les
joueurs je défends les joueurs et je
tacle et je tacle et je taxe sauf ce qui
en lui disant
bon blague de players blame the game
quoi voilà donc vu que c'est un peu toi
qui fais les règles j'ai envie de
traiter
bah oui non mais c'est vosges la tétée
directeur d'une entreprise et le truc
cool dit oui c'est tous les employés
c'est des cons pour moi j'étais très
bien
ah non il se trouve que l'on en fait en
fait non voilà bah mais c'est beau non
ben voilà c'est comme ça on démarre on
démarre la journée on démarre bien la
journée du jeu qui dit comme ça mais son
titre déjà en partie dans la presse et
que les faits n'ont pas trahi demandé de
dire que ces gens mais si nous que ces
chiens doivent se jouer le titre en
rapide et ambitieux si c'est pas un
problème ça vous tient contre tacler du
mans mais elle essaie peut-être tacle et
toi aussi je me remettrai ma gorge
ouais non mais du coup d'envoi gelant
peut défendre les joueurs là dessus les
femmes web et non mais bon y'a ok
c'était juste et non pas amusant du tout
mais messi l'a dit qu'enfin je dire des
x 2 qui ont parlé de notre sport a des
photos des matchs de foot au tas d 00
pourri en la personne qui arrive à dire
où et n'importe quoi le shoot entourent
pas de sponsors c'est une fois de temps
en temps comme ça bon il s'est quand
même pas tout les ronds nous aider final
une heure trente depuis le début de
grand prix sa première vente
non mais en gros à ce que ce que je veux
dire fois je suis 100% d'accord avec toi
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que le
problème une nouvelle fois un jeu s'est
passé comme si tu as un site un mec les
malades chez pas il peut plus marcher il
a plus rien et là tu as tu as une
ampoule au pied
bon alors qu'elle-même lille en phase
terminale quoi fait c'est un détail ce
qui s'est passé hier
c'est à dire que c'est papa c'est pas
pour ça que tu trouves pas de sponsors
j'ai ramené ses cadres à mika on va
interdire le rock dire à un moment donné
c'est ça c'est que tel mais qu on est en
train de réfléchir ce faux lui amputer
le pied parce qu'il est une gangrène et
tu as tu as aussi un nom l'incarner
attention bien le mec est entre la vie
et la mort qui vient de se prendre une
balle
dans le genou tu vois il est mal est là
et là tu as le docteur qui arrive à
tiens tu es dans son petit peu sale qui
a peut-être une carie d'ailleurs pas tu
as he came alerte de la mort pas mais
c'était un coup modo ça c'est un peu ce
à quoi s'est c'est un peu c'est un peu
sa fin du coup oui ces médecins sont
complètement incompétent en plus comme
des 100 dollars adam g du campus se
recrée dans ces parties quoi lui tout le
lot non mais c'est comme la disait il
dit en fait ils critiquent le blitz et
les rapidement toute leur carrière ils
chient dessus mais pendant toute leur
carrière
dès qu'ils sont retraités ah tiens je ne
fais plus que des événements blitz et
rapide
en fait à critiquer ça toute ta vie puis
dès que tu joues pour t'amuser bah tiens
tu ne fais que ça
geneviève en fait je trouve toujours en
toile de fond sont bas parce que c'est
le seul jeu amusant oui ça je comprends
mais pour qu'ils ont critiqué du coup à
l'époque tu ne sais pas non plus a dit
que c'est parce qu'ils sont plus forts
en lan et ils ont peur des rapides et
des blitz qu'ils ont peur bah oui mais
c'est logique mais décotées
dès que leur carrière est finie la tient
en fait je ne joue plus que des beats et
des rapides c'est bon alors nous vole
c'est mieux
ouais alors que tu critiques que tu dis
que c'est n'importe quoi ce ne sont pas
des échecs en fait huit jours que ça
dure c'est quand même incroyable alors
n'est pas forfait surtout la seconde
c'est marquer 1-0 ce serait
extraordinaire
bon point les mots ceci marque 1-0 et
karine sinon tous les russes sont
forfaits en fait ce sera extraordinaire
ils protestent contre contre split os
android qui ne perd il ya combien pas
voilà
je vais la news nulle part je les vois
un petit coup de foudre quand même au
cas où il dit sur chaz sur 2007 sanchez
6-1 0-6 oui mais ça peut être une erreur
de paix gènes qui envoie et du coup
comme il récupère tous le pedn au même
endroit c'est à celle plus de 700 de
chasse ci-contre le vélo s'il ya fort
face aux poteaux
la fédé russe a été bannie par l' agence
antidopage plus de russes aux échecs à
ça par contre c'est possible ça par
contre c'est possible ce serait
extraordinaire que maximo alain ils
seraient pas augmentés jamais allée
andré qui joue ouais mais si andré
kimbuta
pourquoi andrew keen jour eux je serais
pour quoi qu'ils fassent tous forfaits
des russes maxim qualifié quoi plus de
russes antidopage
on va écrire quand même pour les
sponsors ce serait extraordinaire non
fab
non mais c'est impossible ait eu 10 dans
ce cas andré kiné jacquot serait forfait
aussi serait extraordinaire il y aura
pas de journée un autre à ce serait
génial on dit ça sent le fake
moi j'ai envie de te dire on va mettre
des faits 14 sur le coup sûr c'est fake
je suis dans le coup sur twitter je ne
veux rien de bien intéressant sujet mme
nahra quand il sert des mains il se met
limite à plat france crif repris si ça
m'a fait marrer
non mais cela avait tout à eux d'être un
genre de rubinstein
ouais voilà exactement bon déjà bon la
fidh n'a pas mis de statut depuis 4h et
enfin comme ce serait une excellente
nouvelle
bon alors on en pense que nepomniachi
bien joué 4 à navarra les bleus une
council déjà non mais non ces 4,9
fantastique et c'est que celle aussi des
revers contre j'ai le droit au bordel et
kf3 d410 c'est n'importe quoi non mais
par contre maxime mais c'est sûr que
c'est ça la partie mais c'est bon les pn
sont remis ces bons femme a laissé par
tant que l'alliance ou choquer nos cuba
en anglais le hasard mais c'est sûr
qu'il était préparé par les rouscoff en
drag queen ouais c'est sûr bas où il
faisait sa vie tout ça le mais bon en
tout cas si là qu'on lui proposait de
l'adsa ce serait pas étonnant c'est sûr
on va voir ce que ça donne faim pour le
moment c'est ce que je veux que tout le
monde joue contre contre maxime way en
reprenant exactement si la wii peut voir
des petits soucis topaloff avait sa
ronde 1 1
mais il a changé un peu par est ok mais
comme il a joué de 4,3 un peu différente
mais il a il va tout fallout 3 non bah
je pense enfin si veut refaire le trou
de crier quine radjabov ouais on va voir
ce que ça donne alors cela la taupe
d'ouverture anglais ça donne un jeu
ouvert vous fermez pas ça dépend comme
ça devant l'adversaire mais plutôt fermé
pas semi-ouvert vous savez faire mais
même ça dépend tellement en fait ça
dépend de ce que tu joues après il a
fait 4-1 à ok mais ça y est toujours
bien peu par un maxime au dessus j'ai vu
plein de débat qu'on ne se vident leurs
reçus qui est d'être au chiffre de match
il a jamais eu de problèmes sociaux
après peut-être qu andry qui ne veut
juste aller en départage
c'est le reste sa logique avant je vous
comme sa journée alors côté nepomniachi
c'est une anglaise et une espagnole
navarra on s'en fiche mais c'est une
anglaise aussi
et oui en mach 1 c il a fait couper cinq
échecs car attention l'avais jamais vu
non bon enfin je me se désiste m
mais non voyons plutôt ouais mais
peut-être qu'on a joué admet que c'est
une fausse mais tu vas jeu tarnais dans
la base ouais je suis déjà en
exploration façon il ya échec donc a pas
trop de coups pour les noirs non même
s'il ya une partie des poubelles là
dessus et 8 c si c'est quand même le
coup de plus logique mais on la remonte
en fait à la 5e film et rock
du coup j'imagine ou d'écarter les polos
ne vendent que paulo bien que les blancs
voilà lors des 4 as connu pour le jouer
ah oui je me rappelle il y avait eu des
4es quoi après je comprends à trop basse
à partir de centres en organisant où ce
taux qui bouge oui c'est moi qui vous
gps un oui oui fab
voilà c'est mon fab ça tu te rappelles
de tout rater toujours là quoi peut-être
qu'il a une petite idée
non c'est intéressant mais après nous
pour effet le contre et c'était hyper
d'une pièce monsieur chipeau ouais je me
rappelles tu es plutôt aux commandes
non monsieur joueurs ou après blessure
mont des cats et le coup d'être critique
et ne tue peu rauque et tant d'autres où
il a fait des quatre cd à trois décès
d'amd hui trois des huit ab4 bombe deux
parties contre des bots est ce que tu
penses que siné peau rencontre andré kim
en finale le match sera truqué
parce que c'est des russes ont déjà six
secondes son demi oui si j'ai deux
qualités chez moi on a déjà eu le débat
avec les chinois en fait il trouve
d'ailleurs un truc et du tout déjà
malabry que ça arrive mais
bon ferais tu peux pas pas non plus dire
oui c'est sûr ils vont truqués qui est
peut-être peut-être pas mais bien que tu
puisses de plus non mais je pose des
questions que le chat se pose c'est quoi
faire tu vois je j'anticipe les
questions du schatz à 2 ans le chan
canada va prouver que c'est ce truc et
non plus après dernier pourra alors
deviner à la loyale contre contre contre
andry keane aussi quand même par les
gens disent plus gentil si fabre
j'anticipe celle anticipe à la fab
gentil non mais j'en veux plus ces
suspicions
[Musique]
donc on dit jean cecchet firme si ces
questions d'une critique on connaît ses
classiques cavalia 2 qui a et b 4 le
plan de fabre
il connaît ses classiques et aux 28
réserver le fable en fait c'est pas que
je réserverai mais en fait ce qu'on a
tout temps même question et ça fait
chier un moment quoi s'attendre on sait
qu'avec tout on pensait quand même que
le match akhtar atalanta serait truquée
tous les ultras mais notre grosse
discussion sur facebook le badge est
truqué c'est sûr chaque parent va gagner
bons ils ont pris trois tir bas trucs et
non mais je suis très important pour eux
vous rêvez pas la cote en fait sont pris
0 3 à domicile
du coup du coup j'ai coupé e max avait
pris un [ __ ] position mais elle vient
de refaire bref on est assez logique
donc fou prend forcé et il a joué f6
contre nez peau il ya aussi société un
coût possible
marc mais ok faut être enfin je pense
sera pas une armée faux bond les bons
seraient fait un pion ils ont un
meilleur développement neurones aurait
des rockets donc faire un peu attention
quand même un vrai pour réagir au chat
qui dit que peut-être les parties donc
ça prouve que ça privilège plus seul
la profondeur du jeu je suis
complètement d'accord c'est pour ça
alors que moi j'invite tout le monde à
aller jouer aux échecs par
correspondance qui est un jeu quand même
un peu plus profond que c'est parti donc
finalement fab surtout maintenant avec
avec l'aide de dalles de lille à 0 tu
peux faire des parties beaucoup plus
beaucoup de temps pour monde est
vraiment allé chercher la vérité du jeu
donc si vous êtes vraiment la dent dans
la profondeur du jeu et c'est ce qui
vous plaît mais moi ça me plaît aussi
d'ailleurs
dès que j'ai un compte 1 g je m'étais
inscrit à la fédération internationale
des machins et par correspondance et ou
en faire très attention
j'arrivais à les deux parties puisque ça
m'a saoulé parce que c'est juste faux
enfin bon c'est de réunir au camp du non
mais faut beaucoup de temps parce que
pour réfuter leur faim c'est intéressant
comme je mets pour réfuter leur dis tu
passes tes journées vraiment mais c'est
vraiment un jeu intéressant mais du coup
je vous invite tous à le faire et aller
chercher la vraie profondeur et les
vrais partis du haut niveau finalement
donc n'hésitez pas c'est il ya une
fédération s'appelle quoi le yes lycée
cf et moi vous avez vous pouvez jouer
des tournois et tous et surtout
maintenant vous pouvez comparer la vie
de l'île à 0 stockfisch etc
et c'est enfin c'est intéressant
vraiment note que ces trois joueurs ont
joué un coup c'est pas mal quoi mais
vraiment fait fabiano fake c'est un
autre jeu ouais mais c'est pas agir tu
parais c'est un beau jeu quoi non c'est
compliqué et d'ailleurs enfin ces postes
c'est pas du tout évident de devenir
grands maîtres à ce jeu non non je
jouerai six joueurs je me passerais 2000
quoi ben c'est pas sûr tu sois si fort
parce qu améliorer les l'ordi c'est
difficile est vraiment si vous suivez
que la première ligne de l'ordi vous
fait défoncer mais vraiment vous n'avez
aucune chance donc donc ça peut être
intéressant mais serait génial que vlad
qu'on recommence les parties par
correspondance mais quand passer trois
jours vlad arrive sur la position 10
secondes ce coup n'appartient pas à
cette position incroyable trèfle en
bande ku maintenant fait c'est fréquent
que pour sa part il faut consulter les
partis pour un croissance justement
après ce qui est très dur c'est que un
truc qui est jouable par correspondance
tu vas pas vraiment la teneur dramatique
oui ça peut être un cauchemar était tu
peux connaître l' in parker a bomb à
l'autre il n'est pas trois jours à jouer
mais trente secondes de jouer autre
chose et en fait c'est quand même hyper
dangereux mais
mais bon ce qui est intéressant juste ça
va à peu près où ça en avec les patrick
marconato qui est ce qu'elle veut dire
que c'est un homme dispose d'un temps de
réflexion a fini fera pas finira par
battre un ordi un homme avec un temps de
réflexion infinie et l'aide de
l'ordinateur va défoncer un ordinateur
juste lorient n'a aucune chance contre
fatimé stockfisch 10 vs sommes plus
stockfisch du stockfisch 10 ce fait se
fait laminer en fait au mieux finul de
jeu au mieux mais sûrement non parce que
l'homme il va pousser les lignes enfin
bon c'est donc tu va le défoncer alors
quand je dis défoncer des assauts sega
c'est peut-être qu'on va faire sans
parti je vais en gagner dit je vais
faire 90 nul mais c'est énorme c'est
énorme
donc non non c'est un beau jeu je pars
croissance donc je vous invite vraiment
à à essayer si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez vous inscrire donc la fédération
internationale vous pouvez vous pouvez
prendre une licence et jouer des
tournois et ça ça peut vous faire
progresser des roses échec normaux fab
non un vrai bon que je pratique ce n'est
pas évident primés - tu vois des vraies
parties de haut niveau il ya plus de
différence entre correspondance est
longue entre l'ong et rapide par exemple
parce que je dire oui car tu prends le
niveau jeu par correspondance
soumettrait karl scène en classique face
à un mec par correspondance ils joueront
que la danse classique et l'autre
correspondant je pense qu il le détruit
fassi karl scène perd 60 défaites et 40
nul il est déjà très heureux je pense
alors que tu me le même mec avec 2h
carlson cinq minutes je pense carson
yeung possible et tu mets carlsen 20
minutes contre contre ding 1h40
le match est pas clair en fait un
facteur de jean gabin donc la différence
correspondance classique et bien en
terme qualitatif c'est bien plus grosse
différence qu'entre
entre classique et rapide donc voilà
c'est pour faire une petite digression
fab a bien négocié ce lien pendant que
là tu as dit avait joué à fils il avait
joué m6 après e65 ou un coût possible
aussi il y avait eu cinq dans leur parti
ouais 6,5 m je me rappelle de cette
partie une épreuve ayant un petit plus
non et puis il avait gaffé où il avait
au moins une pression on ne te poses
trop trop bien patron de labo peur et
puis à percevoir ce tueur et puis un
moment je peux juste un coup au lycée
fantôme et une pièce eu plus comment oui
je me rappelle les pistes et reçoit une
finale avec deux pions de moins et il
avait perdu les points auprès des points
de fait c'est inouï
mais wayne cette variante juste pour
dire que ce soir avec les noirs déjouer
aussi ci contre
coronary n'en n'ont pas d'accès nord il
était content lautier il a vu les blancs
contre 389 il avait gagné mais c'est ça
et vu sa mémoire c'est que c'est que je
pense qu'ils pensaient que vu que après
qu'une bon je sais pas un max en fait il
est du check les ordis donc maintenant
ces puits et me prépare donc voilà il a
fait aussi se maintenant où ses taux
qu'à vous et moi qui avons en fait à
deux bleus tu atteins bleus un peu un
peu tendre un peu tendre est jeu et un
bleu plus plus ferme quoi plus foncée et
qui dit oui ça c'est la vérité par
zelazny s'allie à tous tient une
anglaise de la sinne que phil capture il
se rappelle aussi bonne mémoire bordeaux
tu pourrais être grand maître hiroo
jeunes qui pensent que c'est également
il nous lâche la première info après
ouais mais je pense que c'est plutôt pas
mince andré qui ne s'en sort plutôt pas
mal en ouverture fab c'est mieux que ces
systèmes de londres insipide pour lui ou
où les trompes offs qui ou quoi là-haut
- andré qui il a pas bob bell sortie
d'ouverture d'andré king qui va avoir un
petit truc un peu jouable au pied rif
est nul mais géré c'est mieux que s'il
avait fait que c'est juste fait un
système de l'undd non ouais ouais ouais
bon c'est plus dangereux après ces
melons dans mon avis il va perdre ça il
peut très bien perdre mais il peut
gagner oui va s'illuminer ou une notion
fred weis qui si elles veulent percer
fille non non non non pas du tout faux
encore faut encore que les autres
fassent quelque chose soit nepomniachi
aille en finale soit se gagne le tournoi
donc on a encore de la marge les mecs on
a encore de la marge
on peut dire une question dans le chat
s'était ya quoi sur calibre en d4 taux
grecs 5 ou qu'on n'aime pas mais en fait
tu peux juste rocqué par exemple et tu
te prépares à mettre des tours sur
l'école ouverte et affaire qu'il a eu
c'est un cookie g5 et en fait il ya trop
de monaco kind jamais ton je sais même
pas s'il pourra excéder un peu empêché
par un tour échec croit ses sept tours
échec car elle est celle ci a bouclé les
quatre peut-être je vous conseille pour
protéger c'est pas foutu 100 % mais
moins de cinq champions prend aux
français s'ils sont près de 5
c'est qu'un des problèmes de partout
tout le temps va toujours sans aucune de
dépit à ce week end j'ai envie dit ralph
à 0 de quoi
oui et c'est un problème fait bon dans
l'ouverture c'est pas très bien de faire
que manger les pions hadders jarre même
quand on joue charles 4,5 des quatre can
tous les pions la whey genre tu français
3 6 4
ok t'es pas capable d'aller prendre
encore b2 mais si tu prends pas tes
pleutres oui oui mais je dis ok parmi
ses possibles c'est juste un exemple
qu'en fait tu as déjà mangé des choses
tu peux penser à développer un genre
alors il se trouve c'est faisable de
prendre mais c'est juste un exemple
après suivant les époques ça aurait pu
être pris pour un manque de respect a
battu houston sort pas de son sort
paraît il n'a pas mangé le pion b26
génial avait tellement énervée quand et
regarder les parties
c'est bien de là que ça vient la règle
aux dames obligés de manger cet horaire
de base c'est pas du tout obligé de
manger aux dames sept chiots dame
tranquille on tue couchettes et dames 1
diagonale c'est très bien puis bon les
mecs manger manger et manger puis un
jour à un mec qui a commencé à arrêter
de manger un bon mois de cours
obligatoires
warsage liga et tu m'as manqué de
respect une orange coiffard despatie il
dit si elles veulent gagner ils sont
aussi aujourd'hui j'aimerais des
candidats ces sacs à patates on n'est
pas au bord du coup si sow gagne
aujourd'hui c'est hier qu'il aurait
battu niveau mental ce week end
aujourd'hui déjà sous peupliers ouais un
peu plus qualifiés moyennant il peut
même maxime qui pourraient être
qualifiés ce soir après ciné pop gagne
non non aînés peau c'est quoi c'est une
petite italienne
ah oui en fait c'est la vente avec des
phrases quoi ça ressemble aux italiennes
je me suis refait piégé congé bon en
fait souvent tu assistes bessin que tu
dises espagnol mais si on sait plus ou
moins par les sirènes jouer le contre
carlsag nombreux dit non à oui c'est
contre eux ding la première oui oui j'ai
quatre des quatre dames 1 c'était ok bon
ok sûrement un peu près égales c'est pas
grand chose non donc du coup max qui
réfléchit
et si max père et que se gagnent sans
point de bonus soit qu'ils aillent en
chercher encore deux points de bonus
qu'elle veut alors attends il le pense
je pense que oui si fait neuf points
avec max fait un max en a 14 et quatre
d'entre eux ouais donc il aura besoin
d'un autobus toujours n'est pas facile à
gérer cherchait donc d'être acquis dit
bonjour partout mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas pareil c'est pas un pseudo
twitch à la rigueur dans la puce de mal
à répondre à une fin et youtube ça va a
tant qu'on a pas de problème technique
on arrive à gérer les deux chat mais dès
que ça commence à être un peu chaud on
perd on perd souvent un chat
bonjour une petite noix de cajou lé
assez bien noix de cajou ne se
souviendront jeux de mots des fausses
trône de l'énergie et tourne
actuellement max à 14 points et pau 10
et saucisses à et ceux ci ça y est très
heureux et très autres social est mais
elle va en finale comme ça ce sera
torche et oui s'il va en finale s'est
torché
oui bon c'est mieux ne pas devoir faire
des comptes d'épicier et tout ça n'a
juste on met les cas de figure possibles
en vue d'acheter 15 ans il a arrêté de
psychoter ainsi comme des brebis apories
faudrait un véritable miracle pour que
ça prenne la place de m'vila
ça dépend de me défendre
10e vesle perd ce match c'est plus
tellement un miracle pour que sonaba
contre des pots mais celui qui gagne bon
faut qu'il y ait le tournoi mais bon
gros oui mais bon après non plus corps
doit de battre andrikiené je sais pas
qui au final puisque manninen passant
non non il faut faire gaffe ce que si en
finale même il joue un oui ou un quart
yakine ces failles peut prendre un point
de bonus surtout contre oui contrecarre
yakine coupure mais car iachini l'air
tellement démotivés non mais tout cas il
donnant à tous déjà dès la demi-finale
postés devant
mais donc bref tout ça pour dire que en
gros mc ça dépend surtout de lui il
qualifie la par contre là où il faut un
miracle pour se fasse mais sinon c'est
pas tant un miracle quoi c'est un
domaine du possible
j'aimerais bien un bon 30 % c'est donc
non maxime qui doit se qualifier en
revanche si si c'est n'est peau qui
passe contre sow le match en demi sera
hyper important puisque la finale de
l'autre côté le tableau est tellement
ouvert prise ça n'est pas j'ai pas envie
de faire un dépôt en finale contre oui
navarra où il ya qu enfin il sera
illustra favori dans dans les trois cas
surtout content navarra où il ya coderre
ouest imagine tu veux navarra en finale
pour te qualifier aux candidats
ac c'est le penalty quoi palmarès je me
suis qualifié aux candidats en battant
en battant la marque enfin fou bah ouais
c'est ça en fait ils veulent pas s'il
affronte le vainqueur denis peau est
exactement
du coup pour soit plus simple c'est vaut
mieux qu'ils affronteraient slattery
et voilà après tous ces braves s'ils
gagnent ce match
guéna domination des qualifiés pour qui
ce passe oui oui oui oui tu as bien tu
as bien résumé le le cas de figure après
aujourd'hui quand même une partie très
importante aux fab pour le vent y prend
son temps m donc c'est mieux que de
débiter l'ouverture n'étant pas sur quoi
réfléchir s'il perd contre sow départage
sebou et non c'est ça oui même si sow se
qualifie maintenant avec le point de
bonus et qui joue conte maxi maxime
aurait juste besoin en 2002 de faire
deux nuls pour se qualifier
exactement exactement
checa tanguy oui c'est vrai mais en
toute franchise si andry kinda mvele
dans cette partie si ça voudrait dire
qu'elle veut elle était trop fait pour
les huit candidats challenger de 400 oui
mais j'ai envie de te dire qu'ils
d'autres achetés catalan ouais non mais
en fait même en cas de défaite pour le
coup fois encore sous pas c'en est un il
gagne le tournoi avec un point de bonus
ou que vous preniez pauvres c'est un
truc au moins finale août et ils
viennent je sais pas va se dire que sur
l'ensemble des trois tournois
une édition trois temps à ce n'est pas
un tendre et en fait beau match a été
assez régulier les finalistes demi
finalistes c'est pas mal il n'y pas ok
d'un gagnant il est pas du premier tour
l'autre même il un rien est perdu deux
fois au premier tour donc sans faute
c'est pire bien sûr et puis il ne faut
pas oublier que c'est la dernière place
à prendre
c'est logique que les places des joueurs
qui sont les plus dangereux soient
prises et le début c'est à dire caruana
dink il avait quasiment leur place
assurée dès le début c'est comme les
deux plus dangereux et après comme on
l'a déjà dit assez souvent dit gay
caruana c'est quand même clairement les
numéros 2 et 3 mondiales donc après
quand tu vas chercher en dessous bah tu
te retrouves avec forcément des joueurs
qui semblent a priori moins dangereux
comme radjabov huang dao dans une
moindre mesure gif assez normal en fait
plus tu vas chercher loin pardon je joue
oui - tu vas tomber sur dean caruana et
plus les joueurs auront eu un parcours
difficile et long pour obtenir leur
place c'est logique je connais quelqu'un
qui venait pas jeunes n'ont donc mais
bon on a eu très très optimiste
maxime père perd seulement je pense
qu'il mérite beaucoup plus conne et pau
d'y aller mais après tu as pour moi si
on avait un vin j'ai déjà dit plusieurs
fois mais pour moi il y en a un qui
mériteraient ok mérite mieux que maxime
et qui mériterait un peu ses sauts ouais
mais en fait il n'a pas fait une bonne
saison mais sinon sur le niveau
intrinsèque oui oui mais il est quand
même champion du monde de 960 c'est vrai
gert à fait nouvelle oui je suis
d'accord il a fait une mauvaise saison
classique mais pour moi ce titre il veut
dire beaucoup
c'est pas si anodin que ça pour moi
d'avoir gagné ce tournoi là mais on nous
demande ce qui se passe sur eux cinq
autres quelques heureux que l'option b
je dois faire grand retour mais pas se
faire prendre sur échec côté à toi alors
à temps il ya un coût ya eu six au kenya
peut être pas ils répètent pas et n'a
peut être pas ce qu'est le compte de
dépôt il fait aussi c'est donc deux
coups de gueule mais aux 5 juste pour
dire leurs dix 10 prises rien voit deux
prises
sa double attaque voit ses sept pieds
poings f7 lucho marchenay entourage
c'est peut-être vrai tu gagnes un tempo
là dessus ou b 7e france est ici s'il te
fais ok bref cet homme peut-être ça la
les plus facile expliqué un peu l'euro
prête à ça en l'air en plus à la fin
cher que tu fais ça il fait sa ba c'est
la varende complète en fait le
redoublement est un pion plus à la fin
ouais donc pour en revenir à la partie
la feo 6-max donc il a pas joué les
vestiges comme il avait joué contre
dépôt donc au moins déjà évité une
grosse préparation
si vous surveillez et c'est un coup
intéressant simplement parce que tu
attaques des quatre îles et tu sors tu
manges aux tons chaud trop chaud en
fuite alors là il ya deux autres
apparemment femmes souvent joué avec 3 e
de soi avec rock faut prendre la
décision enfin en tout cas avant avant
avant fou prend b4 ouais bon jeu en
général ils font
ils font anges et surtout prend b4 pour
la paix gnafu pranger set je pense ça va
faire un coup comme fou 17 serait
logique et les blancs pourraient mettre
les tours au centre très rock tu peux
aussi faire réussissent pour sortir ton
fou peut-être c'est ce que ce qui est
joué parfois que se portent tous des
sept coups mais servent aux deux parties
ont croqué f6 ou fou 17 huras est celle
ci peut être candidat mais j'imagine
plutôt fou 17 en premier ouais j'ai
l'impression que ça donne plus de
flexibilité ou 17 hockey ce qui s'est
souvent passé c'est que les blancs
prennent ans et six bons mois les deux
prix sont possibles on vous prend qui
avalise 5 et jean reuilles 8 es tu as un
peu et blanc faire leur vie elles dame
mais c'est possible tout ce tout
s'échange trop tard quand j'arrive à
prendre et mettons y prends tu prends il
fait tout racisme et en gros je
comprends que tu reprends des quatre
fers tour c'est un toit tout prendre
mais les noirs petit à petit tu t'en
sors tu vas faire et on peut montrer
peut-être une vente illustratif le roi
17 ans et 6 pour ces huit tours prend
tout reprend tourasse est bon mais
heureusement on a des sujets soit dans
la vente d'armes à la côte
je pensais que tu attends c'est 7 hélas
oui voilà genre truc
ouais en fait c'est ça l'idée dé notre
bon droit et fi 3g 8 fait fuiter on
touche plus à rien j'ai six fours g7 et
c'est fini mais le plan est inévitable
il n'y a pas assez de jeu pas assez de
pièces vont mettre la pression
on nous dit kdg voilà déjà de résultat
décisif aux fables dans cette journée
nul entre nespresso et pour esso voilà
et bah du coup se retrouveront en
départage ils se retrouvaient demande et
partagent donc premiers résultats
premier résultat décisif aujourd'hui
femmes et c'est plutôt un résultat qui
nous arrange envie de te dire bah oui on
fait ton gaffeur enfin décent il y aura
un cahier lien entre les deux autos de
60 ans un ministre
oui voilà première première bonne
nouvelle c'est que si maxime l'emportent
aujourd'hui il sera pas encore qualifié
messersi l'emporter aujourd'hui est que
solent portes demain ce sera fini donc
bons résultats une partie c'est vrai
qu'il nous a offert un grand spectacle
aujourd'hui encore entre nepomniachi et
ce au juste la destinée de l'espagnol
soit débité un truc qui va très bien
pour les noirs qui sitôt maxime qui a
fait fou dès cette semaine à tizi 28
minutes n'est peau et sow pleutres non
mais enfin comme je disais en
introduction dont blind players blame
the game c'est pas les joueurs le
problème c'est pas les gens le problème
mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu
étonnant de passer sa vie à dénigrer les
rapides quand là on voit que dans les
tournants importants
les joueurs
a fortiori ne joue pas en longues c'est
un peu étrange d'avoir ces deux jours
deux parties longues là qui viennent un
petit peu pollué le spectacle mais bon
on n'écrit pas encore les règles fab
nous offrir à tous un jour moi je pense
pas je pense pas c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu un petit peu décevant andré
keane est allé chez le kiné pour se
faire poser un drain
je sais pas ce que c'est un drain du
coup boss un truc pour écouler quand tu
aimes tu es bien malade quoique sa ligne
un jeunot ou le pas vu ou mais c'est à
dire que tu as quoi que tu as un
problème au docteur un problème un tuyau
mais un tuyau pour plein de trucs mais
bon et qui dispose pâti d'un je
comprends pas c'est un truc d'hôpital
quoi je sais pas je pense que c'est un
fake fille qui nous tuait peut-être
regard sur les images
moi je dois vous et sur ses deux fils
d'houphouet sur youtube de la fidh
ouais mais j'ai pu aller même si l'un
d'entre eux sera extrait passionnel va
se qualifier ne sais pas je te regarde
passer par le chas plus tôt finie font
rien walsh est un saint et disent que
c'est un fake un message je ne suis même
pas compris le jeu de mots fois ne s'est
pas qu'on fonce dedans on sait juste que
normalement il ya un fond de drôlerie ou
quoi non mais bon un moment donné
l'humour a laissé le nous en fait
ok la partie ça ressemble à la ligne
administrative
donc ok qui est synchro et 8
ça pourrait solder sur une île très
rapide de femmes ça peut ça peut vous
dire ok processus c'est normal
franchement je te dis un truc sissach
fait deux nuls comme ça je mets au lieu
du résumé je mets un montage de ludwig à
la place enfin on va parler on va pas
refaire une vidéo là dessus c'est c'est
pas prêt peut-être il a essayé de la
joindre et qu'il met la vente qu'on a
donnée par et paraîtrait logique n'est
ce pas oui car c'est ici
bc on avait dit quoi tour à 6 c'est
quand même le coup logique par
excellence mais ouais en fait derrière
il ya un truc marrant dans la partie
l'autre espoir votre look effet tour à
quatre bacs et prince et six blessés
tour à 88,36 ont juste eu à sortir ton
foot aurait fait un bref cette tour à
cette 37.7 phone 7
ok loti a fait pour ces sept proposer
une accepté là mais là il y avait
toujours y avait ces cinq uturbey 8 je
me rappelle un émir n'était pas cessé
son exercice encore connue oui on va
dire ces cinq garçons parce que si les
30 ans des vitres du couloir et c5 b52
tu fais tomber vite quand même et puis
tu as gagné bio et gary avait raté ça
bon ok juste en fait ceux de faire enfin
la partie de radio à 3 heures comme dame
pour genève un coup et qui ont fait
juste eu ces axes nuls et film est
attendu mais proposer des crous dans la
main tu regardes une tempête mais oui il
avait raté sa chance et a dû l'accepter
numérique et il prend ses six baissé moi
je m'attends vraiment à tout racisme
mais je sais pas pourquoi j'ai connu ce
biais d'un vote ça je suis qu'elles
soient publiées dans un livre semi connu
et puis après il fait un peu le tour du
monde
tu pense qu'on va réussir à faire nul en
moins d'une heure aujourd'hui pas
peut-être là c'est très dépendants de
reiki notion est ce que ce qui joue un
coup il propose nul ou bob ouais je
m'attends vraiment à une une rapide
femmes
ben écoute sais pas si nos montres frau
pas avec les noirs et puis on s'explique
un rapide à une cadence qui convient
bien max oui oui non ça me paraît ça me
paraît bien ça me paraît bien pour le
spectacle pour nous pour tout le monde
un tel d'heures que descendre les
poubelles on sait pas ce qui se passera
tout retour non mais on est bien
d'accord faible que celle là on
l'analyse pas où on l'analyse quand même
bon on va voir comment ça dure à ce
qu'il soit se trouvent y aura un
vainqueur on sait pas pourquoi
si ça se passe normalement il revenu le
rapid voilà je mets best of twitch les
montages de lui dit mieux que les nuls
rapide ouais quand tu fais ce que tu
veux non mais je vois pas vraiment un an
ça ne paraît pas aussi se passe rien sur
ces noms mais autant l'a fait hier mais
on peut pas faire ça tous les jours
à un moment donné donc gas oil qui les
blancs jouent en premier comme je
l'avais anticipé fab un jeu trop quoi
dire pour l'instant
non mais on l'a vu l'appareil est
illustrative toutes les variantes donne
plus ou moins sa fab banon y énormément
de nuls dans des parties ont été jouées
dans cette ligne du coup je vous cache
pas que c'est quand même le scénario
attendu
tu donnes quoi à 95% 97 même bon 90 à 98
ouais je vais une pub
ah ok tout de suite en version en
fanfare les bim ce parti femmes la pub
est parti
voilà qu'on dit florence 1 et 2 peut se
planter ils sont et ben voilà c'est ça
après si les blancs gagne a et c est qu
un organe b4y les rangs même pas cherché
à voir que l'on tue pas quoi dire fable
nombreux soutiens se passe bien tes
journées sur paris sinon c'est cool ça
va ça va ce matin j'ai fait un peu court
ce soir quand même il ya l'événement
satee pari foot
ouais tu vas aller suivre ça dans un
petit bar tu as regardé miss france hier
soir j'ai pas vraiment regardé je
passais devant un moment voilà j'ai pas
regardé plus que ça jean pierre foucault
me fait un peu peur pourquoi il fait il
a fait quoi et jp je sais rien qu'en
fait il est il est marron quoi
maintenant et puis il a des bosses sa
tête le ban qui tient donc le tan tient
très bien mais il doit se botoxée à fond
il a dit joue de 26 terre mais aussi des
peaux mates lattois sur les sourcils pas
je sais pas quoi
c'est vrai que nature qui les dérider
c'est la vie c'est pas grave
ouais c'est jean pierre foucault ouais
mais c'est un peu ça fait de la peine je
vois combien de tris ça te renvoie à ton
propre vieillissement
bon j'ai pas en peut-être mais je n'ai
pas pensé comme ça mais bon bref sinon
sinon bah limite je sais pas j'ai vu que
c'était miss guadeloupe qui avait gagné
à elle était favorite part j'aime bien
mais ceux de martinique
sinon il y avait les mythes du sud qui
était pas trop mal je crois qui est
inquiétant et 5,5 dernière d'ailleurs
elles sont bien battus bas mais je
connais même pas le podium en fait moi
non plus mais donc voilà bon gros miss
france j'ai pas vraiment regardé
quoi d'autre oui non ce soir mais non je
galère un peu avec la grève des
transports je suis pas fait pour aller
dans le bar des supporters de sainté
quoi j'ai droit à ça une heure à pied
j'ai déjà fait ailleurs c'est rien pour
toi
non ça va surtout si la ja nul dans 5
minutes là j'ai mon après mais bon si on
finit tard qu'on va faire la vidéo
machin il à quelle heure le match je
crois que c'est le dernier la soirée
donc ce genre 21h t'as le temps tu
attends tu vas être large
ah ouais quand on s'attend une nulle si
20 minutes vous que oui je peux
peut-être même y aller en marchant sur
les mains et arrivent à l'heure drogba
tu te sens tu sens la victoire à da ce
soir ça va être dur je sais pas on n'est
pas en forme ont eu un petit effet de
plus elle au début puis la coup de mou
et paris je sais pas chaud qui sont
chauffés dans un match difficile
non mais en plus c'est qu'on y entend
une stat que neymar à marie houk les
équipes en ligue 1 s'offre un témoin du
coup va vouloir absolument marquer pour
enlever ça ouais tu fous match difficile
ce soir fable mais bon tu vas tu as
quand même être à fond derrière thierry
par une balle perdue
mais bon au moins que contact coiffant
commencent un truc faisait tacle tu es
déçu tu apprécies sur le terrain voilà
on suit offs qui non mais c'est de jouer
si on est dépassé on tacle voilà c'est
ça c'est ça le principe entoure à 4 ce
que la partie de garrigue bon peut-être
que andry qui ne peut nous faire tort
c'est cet été mais elle n'accepte pas de
nul effet ces cinq qui gagne quoi bon
pour le coup dans ce set c'était pas
obligé on est bon on pourrait faire un
truc comme roy f1 et les plus nomades du
couloir juste c'est nul 1-1 rodino la
partie c'était un f6 ouais ben ouais
ouais
vous c'est toi c'est toi cette tour à 7
3 7 6 3 et enfin web par exemple un stop
and go away genre tourbe et 8 mois tu es
fou et 3,3 de prendre b4 non encore le
nom et on se sait pas même le sol et il
faut prendre trois noms avant de prôner
l'arrêt
non mais du coup se débloque de faire un
auto sous on atterrit un pion ces
tensions il trouve c'est nul mais c'est
les gens qui doivent régler les affaires
nouvelles donc donc ces noirs qui sont
plutôt un peu mieux investi tu fais tour
c'est cette fronde est captée changement
des captures france à 6 début de perdre
4 ints paraît sans fab est là au moins
il n'y a plus de débat mais ouais
beaucoup de ça peut ça peut entraîner
donc c'est vraiment la variante d'avoir
dans laquelle on se tend un mousse sur
ali réseau phil rogers bah en fait lire
on a émis des idées
quelqu'un devrait investir sur lui pour
gagner l'argent voilà lui propose cent
mille par an pour les piscines team
d'entraînement des grosses prépa à tout
ça mais en votre parti peut-être tu
prends 50% sur ses gains pendant 10 ans
ou cinq ans pour trouver l'accord mais
on a lancé une idée et grâce à ça il
pourrait vite essayer d'intégrer le top
10 mondial et peut-être viser le titre
de champion du monde parce que le
potentiel il l'a mais après maintenant
c'est en plus de potentiel faut vraiment
être hyper prennent aux ouvertures
c'est donc il n'y a pas 150 coach qui
peuvent eux tu peux vraiment amnis ce
savoir la cua y en a un qu'on connaît
mal qui d'autre quito thouet
en fait non dans sa vie on peut faire
une cagnotte litchi mais c'est la
commission va on va prendre ce nouveau
ils vont tous vos cahiers plein de fric
pour faire du rapid quoi on veut toucher
des pourcentages fois dans des shows
quoi ce que je suis fan de lescar bref
les scans je veux pas mal à l'époque
bah ouais c'est une bonne équipe c'est
un bon club moi quand je t'ai pistons
emprunt division quoi sa belle équipe
le masi dan micoud joueurs comme le dira
si ce n'est bien le milieu de terrain
lorsqu'il ya demain les mecs bah écoute
à demain mais on vous en veux pas si
simple si vous partez vous pouvez
peut-être raté un truc incroyable mais
honnêtement si vous s'il fait beau chez
vous et que vous avez un dimanche
après-midi à choisir et ce que je sors
un peu je faire un tour machin où je
suis je suis les commentaires jusqu'au
bout on va pas vous mentir
là on attend la nulle femmes du coup on
apparaître jean pierre foucault quoi
d'autre quand et cannois tu supportes
pas logis ceni sauf si tu es un traître
exactement style at home en fait des
niçois y est qu une histoire donc
supporter je ne parle pas de ce club à
sa secrète de m'intéresse pas oui je
pense
dommage que j'aie jamais rencontré de
supporters niçois ailleurs en france
alors que cannes beaucoup
brian gens savent plus maintenant c'est
un bon club acheté 15 ans il vous parlez
de quel entraîneur dorfman alors non aux
normes pad pour le haut niveau
aujourd'hui c'est c'est eh bien quand il
entraînait etienne ou quoi mais c'est
plus un entraîneur deux joueurs du top
plutôt bon à nous parler de vlad pour
rigoler mais sinon il ya pas mal
d'entraîneurs il peut avoir raison de
cette manière
non mais tu peux essayer de débaucher
kazim il ya quasi vrai ok peut-être je
sais pas toutefois que parce que ça
donne
je n'aime pas sûr d'être livrés mais ce
serait dans ce genre la mairie attend de
cette puce
je crois oui mais voilà où les virus sur
notre 26,50 et 2007 la whey non mais tu
peux faire tu peux faire une équipe
battue veut faire wlad fy gritche l'a
toujours pas appelé d'ailleurs ce qu en
soit il est libre tant que d or etienne
ce serait bien mais bon boulot il occupe
avec ma chrétienne il serait excellent
et il n'est pas libre alors on réfléchit
un peu au joueur qui vaut personnes qui
peuvent être libres et on entendra en
dessous qu une autre peut-être il va pas
de faire trop de préparer dans le show
de compote il est juste très érudit va
te paraît un peu de tout des plans il va
pas il va pas rendre l'ordinateur il
déteste ce avant le choc landes il veut
pas y toucher en fait ça peut être pas
mal pour un stage mais pas pour secondes
en tête mais no fake parce que c'était
moskalenko qui me répondent moskalenko
qui la seconde évolué en tout cas bon
bah oui pour préparer et jouer aux dames
quoi ça n'intéressait pas vraiment été
obligés de manger tu me respectes donc
puisque le respect non mais rien j'en
sais rien ça peut être ça peut être un
façon qui s'il est toujours libre ici à
part un truc secret ou quoi non mais ça
en fait le truc c'est que après faut
voir que tu as des entraîneurs enfin les
entraîneurs pour tous les niveaux
les gens qui peuvent amener à niveau à
un autre le tda passé m voire même un
petit de grand maître etc
mais là on parle vraiment pour le top
top top mondial et est du coup il ya peu
d'entraîneurs qui peut vraiment convenir
enfin n'importe qui peut apporter un peu
sa pierre à l'édifice essayé d'aider
mais un truc vraiment efficace si on a
pas 50 non c'est difficile c'est
difficile c'est pour ça qu'il ya autant
de joueurs qui ont du mal à rentrer au
top top parce que les personnes
compétentes pour t'aider elles se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main et la
plupart sont équipés en gros de la foire
le talent il faudrait travailler autour
de 2007 2007 50 déjà
ok je signerai pas beaucoup qui arrivent
et malgré ça après fort la chance de
nantua c'est très difficile mais tu as
tout madoff je pense je pense c'est fini
aussi pour le top top sont pas ceux ci
n'auraient emirates chine est tous
pareil non à windows
c'est sur palm chine très bien justement
ce que je formais des jeunes ou s'est
passé et miou quoi puisque un certain
stade il votre excellent et on peut
prendre bien des brèches 2005-2006 bas
comme dorfman en fait
mais après presque fini comme dorfman
c'est bien jusqu'à un certain niveau
après l'es10 uzi à toi favorable moi je
pense que non moi je peux l'aider à
passer jean jusqu'à imi qui est
peut-être le grand maître aller mais
c'est tout quaprès peut pas vos mots des
plus que déjà je n'ai pas fait pour moi
même quoi donc c'est dur de faire pour
d'autres elle est mêlée quelqu'un un
serbe pendant un moment puis après que
passe la main à quelqu'un d'autre pour
mieux est ok ok ça arrive même dans tous
les sports quoi tu as des entraîneurs de
foot spécialisé pour les u17
mais du coup tu as peut-être entraîner
des génies énormément aidé mais après
tenir un groupe pro c'est autre chose
villareal et il serait peut-être pas mal
d'ailleurs peut-être peut-être
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il a encore
jamais fait mais vous êtes ici pas à spa
combat la salle certain recul
il s'appelle grog qui me demandent si je
donne des cours aux jeunes découvrent un
peu moins
vérifie garçons livre comment il a
changé de secondes an pour atteindre le
haut niveau est mais il a été super bien
entouré par paris tianhe-1 s'est il
avait des stages en plus avec beddiaf ce
qui ce qui était très bien ce qui s'est
vraiment un top joueur des années 80 bon
niveau compréhension de jeu des choses
comme ça c'est absolument excellent et
après etienne pour la rigueur est très
grande ouverture parfaite et si je mets
la grosse difficulté c'est de trouver
l'entraîneur numéro un comme ils sont le
stage parce qu'après si une fois que tu
as ton entraîneur et je sais pas on va
dire vide l'air justement comment parler
d'une fois que tu as pris ce vide l'air
il peut prendre
il peut prendre un rat guerre si tu veux
jouer sur les ouvertures que tu joues il
peut même tuer même prendre un cornet tu
pour te faire l'arago sinn
en réalité après tu as beaucoup de choix
celui qui est dur à trouver c'est le
principal c'est celui qui va être plus
érudit que les autres qui va faire le
lien entre tous les autres et qui va qui
va mener le travail après pour trouver
les autres qui seront en dessous c'est
très facile
la liste ne va pas faire des choix c'est
en fait tu peux prendre n'importe qui et
laventie dans un domaine je vais le
prendre
calicots si ça peut être un bon on
n'aurait pas parlé mais il est déjà pris
en bas du cou avec un primeur oui arrive
déjà pris mais ils vont après peut-être
qui peut accepter de faire les deux qui
sont pas encore rivaux d'ivoire kasparov
wef gasparin fille ok il avait un peu
des carlson à un moment mais je pense
qu'à sa sortie du court terme mais
cassard faire un stage ça peut être bien
oui voilà va même on peut en faire
plusieurs c'était c'est fantastique ou
cramique peut-être un autre grammy qui
peut être fantastique on va dire
que ce soit possible mais juste kramnik
tu vas pas l'avoir 28,38 foutu dans ce
sens mille par an 150 milles c'est pas
dans le budget parce qu'il lui faut des
mecs derrière wayne peut-être à 150
mille par an on dans le budget mais
mettez bien non mais y à il ya quelques
quelques quelques personnes après après
c'est un gros budget sur par ailleurs
elles mêmes même grille choo que s'il va
pas au candidat ou quoi et s'il envoie
100 milles c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
switch
moi je vous dis aujourd'hui donc oui
mais voyons pas partir d'avril si si
l'éclair enfin s'il va pas au match
championnat du monde
c'est possible si l'on voit 100000
parents qui prennent le truc et
chrétiens qui doit tour est assez bien
abbas qui serait bien meiway gens sont
choqués du poisson c'est terminé c'est
ce qu'on dit en fait enrichir
on parlait de ce serait intéressant que
quelqu'un fortunés venus faire un
investissement et propose un partenariat
je te finances des premières années je
paye
cent cinquante mille par an par exemple
mais un échange je prends 50% sur des
gains pendant tant d'années je sais pas
ce qu'ils comme on disait à ce que des
femmes c'est que les joueurs à haut
niveau
ils vont gagner dans le top 10 au moins
200 250 mille par an et si tu as la
chance qu'il vienne champion du monde il
va prendre 3 4 millions donc tu prends
des risques mais ces calculs et femmes
ben oui en fait tu vas pas investir sur
tout le monde mais j'ai un fil rogers
tout sur glace peut vraiment être
intéressant
c'était notre d'autres qu'on discussions
d'hier et on leur prend aujourd'hui mais
on n'a pas trouvé quelques noms après il
faut il faut en trouver un avec qui ça
match parce que ce si important que ça
match au niveau des caractères et qu'ils
soient libres ce que j'aime c'est que
regardent prendre le grand jeu ce tour
j'ai la liste des prix des gens ce
qu'ils ont pris cette année donc d'inga
niagane il a pris 2 194 que mais c'est
juste sur un circuit de tournois ça
compte pas la coupe du monde ça compte
pas le jeu qu'au niveau de rapidité truc
un must have en gueule et on sait et on
compte pas les honoraires oui mais bon
ok ça c'est ce qu'il a gagné
voilà oui mais karlsson 302 cas aragon
soit 161 milles car yakine cas rien fait
de ouf 99000 à nantes 97000 sow 110000
est ok le pire du pire du pire c'est
mamediarov qui a fini dernier a pris 48
mines donc en fait tout ça pour vous
dire que si avec cet investissement tu
atteins ce groupe de joueurs après ses
bons côtés si vite rentable grèce et la
partie ça se peut que les deux soient au
courant de la partie 2 qui sera pas de
la partie
gary à 100% derrière bon ben ok faut
faire bref cette étendre le piège
ouais
donc c'est vrai que cette force et ça
c'est fantastique
ok donc la relève c'est à ton tour cette
grosse faute on espère ajoutons à ces 7
ckoi le piège on allie chabat tour c'est
cette liasse et 5 qui est à gagner pour
les noirs parce que plus on prend pas
possible il ya tourbe et vite
éduquons attaque le four b2 qui peut pas
s'en aller signature bien matt et bien
sinon bah si l'on en fait sur ces cinq
comptes il défend trompions neymar
veulent te faire ses preuves et 4 et si
tu fais c'est 5 pb 5 je veux dire de
façon il ya 4 ans baby voilà tu as bien
résumé cours bons rôles moment de mettre
une cuisse va parce que c'est peut-être
le sait le moment décisif de la partie
je ne sais pas de pub on se retrouve
dans une minute pour savoir si la fée
tour c'est ça tout pas si c'est pas
obligé bien sûr il ya d'autres ph qui
est là qui rigole qui nous fait nous lol
quand on fait ce qu'on peut farah jeu
s'appellera série tour c'est 7 août et
pleutres normalement non mais il peut
faire
je crois qu'il fera ce qui est beau
quand même c'est que si la partie se
finit comme ça on aura à lâcher la
partie une nouvelle fois après dix
minutes de commentaires
on a lâché tout là toute la partie
diéval adam là on a vraiment montré
cette position il ya longtemps avant de
parler de jean pierre ou quoi avant de
chercher des sponsors avant tout évident
puisque je choisis les flux non je ne
choisis pas les pubs je choisis
simplement le moment où je mets les pubs
là ces moments décisifs
gardons tous les coups font nulle torse
tout ça ce retour soit quasiment mais
tous ces autres mondes c'est gagnant
c'est pas gagné ses sept c'est ça non
mais un très cool quoi enfin
3 tu vas prendre des 5 pouces et 3
montrent un gros avantage
un minimum c'est ça c'est fini
si fait tour c'est cette vidéo sinon
mobile arabe qui ne t'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer bien se passer de passion
pour cette chaude
de quoi gâcher ça car je sais pas quoi
j'ai vu un truc plus haut non mais faut
pas fâcher rojas avril 2007 à saison
quand même quoi on a d'autres qui ont
mieux gâcher leur carrière que lui quoi
toi non plus d'ailleurs
c'est juste que en fait ok il faut pas
perdre de temps font briller tout de
suite que même avec tout ça on n'est
jamais sûr à 100% que ça marchera oui
mais au moins pour mettre toutes les
chances de son côté droit il ya beaucoup
de joueurs qui sont arrivés à peu près
au niveau de fil rouge à et qu'on a
pensé qu'ils pourraient être champion du
monde et en actions réussies comme 40
scène et puis il y en a qui ont raté
commanderie queen we may jardin liquide
dont la soie nylon
mais ouais avec lui le conseil de la
préfecture sa petite ville de berne
y at il plus de 100 kg à surfer au japon
capturent ce vendredi après c'est pas
nous qui l'aimé tant on va te c'est
juste ont parlé comme ça si quelqu'un
veut les mettre sur moi dit plus tôt
qu'il les met juste pour l'instant
salaire moyen fait bref ça a l'air
simple et au delà ça va être un
investissement assez sûre entre
aubrystes 0 pire des cas il sera à 27,50
et déjà te ra portant son investissement
bon il a que 30 points dow a gagné mon
avis c'est faisable
alors bon il dit peut-être ça sera
encore mieux mais pour l'instant dans
saint ylie que 2004 entre guillemets que
quoi donc tu sais pas s'il avait jusque
là malgré tout mais ça peut être une
bonne idée aussi rien
voilà c'est ça c'est comme quand tu
joues en bourse ou mata un truc c'est
sûr ça monte tranquillement tu sais pas
s'attendre à des sommets trop tôt mais
peut-être qu'il courbe
je sens que ça va aller et puis tu as un
truc ça peut monter en flèche
ça peut rester où ça s'est passé dit tu
sais pas quoi bon bah tu peux prendre le
risque que je le truc qui remonte en
flèche à fond mais c'est pas le truc le
plus sûr on nous demande de quelle
équipe pourrait nouvelles s'ils gagnent
les cigales si ce caillou cardinal ce
sera ce sera etienne de te créer l'exo
mon lift et entière confiance pour ça
c'est un
c'est un second dans deux premiers choix
il fait partie de meilleures secondes en
du monde et on est sûr que la compétence
à côté français alliés notre très beau
que le leem ce sera vraiment fou ses
trois buts lancé cette fronde des quatre
temps précise pascal maes est probable
mais là on a tout montré
est-ce que vous avez un resort de ouf
pour contrer les déchets sera l'année
prochaine en pro de châssis gay
couthenans on a décidé de faire une
équipe française comme on a dit que
c'était une compétition par pays on a
décidé de faire une équipe française et
on n'a pas recruté de joueurs étrangers
et puis aussi on n'a pas vraiment envie
de fabre à titre personnel j'ai pas
envie de dépenser l'argent midstream
pour ça je pensais les choses plus
intéressant à faire
non mais encore si on avait des dons
pour ça mais ça que je veux ton argent
perso pour pour rien
non mais je n'ai même pas non mais j'ai
même pas envie d'ouvrir une page de deux
spécialement pour ça enfin je préfère
faire du caritatif que ça on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec fable justement tire
d'ailleurs avant le stream nous explique
dans les échecs il ya un peu de fans
qu'on voit les joueurs comme nadal qui
font des choses pour les autres je
pensais quand il ya eu les problèmes à
majorque et c'est ça que dans les échecs
y a jamais jamais d'initiative
je parle des joueurs de haut niveau je
parle pas des clubs est jamais vraiment
d'initiatives qui sont faites pour
partager ou quoi et peut-être c'est pour
être pas mal de lancer de lancer une
mode jusqu'à l'hôtel et on embauche un
ware est peut-être ce serait pas mal
ce serait pas mal mais mais oui du coup
j'ai pas envie d'ouvrir une page de dons
pour le court pour l'équipe de prod
chasse league
1e convient compétition avec les mêmes
joueurs et de toute façon si l'argent tu
vois il allait à des joueurs qui gagnent
moins ou quoi j'ai envie de dire aux
alentours de 25 26 27 et que c'était
possible pourquoi pas mais là cette
façon pour que ça aille au delà des gens
qui ne sont pas dans le besoin donc ça
m'embête un peu de demander des dons
pour ça alors il a fait pousser trois en
premier alors attention jouez mambé
quatre noms mais l'idée que le oui
arrive un jour hi fi excuse moi j'ai pas
vu la vidéo que là on disait pour ses
sets sont prouvés quatre cantons 7 6
nuls et je crois que
ça va arriver le projet dit evans 2020
tu seras la cup j'espère bien ouais ce
serait sympa le zii event je veux bien
mais sinon on pourrait faire un truc de
notre côté c'est un gros événement d
streamer qui font doivent j'ai cru
comprendre ce devait être un truc comme
ça
mais si ça y est pas tu vois comme on
nous parlait tout à l'heure le 20
juillet qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
pourquoi pas faire un strip de 24 heures
le 20 juillet pour pour pour une
association pour un truc pour montrer
que les échecs basse et ça ça peut un
peu bougé dans ce sens là que ça mais
c'est vrai que ça n'existe pas du tout
dans les échecs
t'as pas un joueur de haut niveau qui
fait que je sache c'est peut-être que je
me trompe et que vous avez des exemples
mais qui est fait vraiment quelque chose
pour partager un petit peu donc voilà je
pense ce serait sympa de montrer que
dans les échecs on est lucide et des
gens qui partageaient qui font des trucs
quoi donc la main sur le coeur ou pas ou
pas ou pas la main sur le coeur tu as de
base - les trucs caritatif suis pas agi
que j'y crois pas à fond mais mais si ça
peut donner un élan et moi c'est plus
dans le délire de dire aidez vous les
uns les autres et la vie c'est pas c'est
pas que penser à sa gueule serait plus
pour ça après les associations je suis
pas je suis pas un grand fan ce sera dur
pour moi de trouver quelque chose mais
c'est plus eux tu vois dans l'esprit que
dans le que dans le truc en soit on
tentera un truc le 20 juillet à nice il
avait des idées d'associations des
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas
la croix rouge la croix rouge non non
d'accueil famose aux esprits wells et
l'esprit score est sinon je sais pas
trop mais leurs deux péages comme tu es
docteur peut-être que tu as une idée de
quelque chose qui est vraiment
fondamentalement ce qu'est ce qui me
fait toujours peur c'est que c'est que
c'est qu'on sait jamais vraiment où ça
va et du complot qui revient attention
bon sinon j'ai une idée ou enfin enfin
vous faites le 20 juillet et on donne
l'argent est là et c'est ce à quoi
qu'ils achètent enfin bon joueur ah oui
tiens très bonne idée
non mais c'était un peu grec torse et ça
tient ça être à la partie non mais
c'était un peu l'intérêt de penser au
téléthon dans le sens où le téléthon je
sais pas c'est tellement médiatisé que
j'ai envie de faire plus confiance mais
après je suis peut-être que moi non mais
ok on pourra le faire aussi son chemin
vers le 20 juillet pour faire un
téléthon 24 heures encore un piolet
association wla tkatchev pour donner des
cours d'échecs à mirta ce cas parce
qu'il est vraiment nulle pour les harvey
renom pour les pour les pour
l'environnement où les humains plutôt
les humains je pensais peut-être un truc
en rapport à la russie peut être aussi
je sais pas mais comme je vous disais
j'aurai besoin de vos compétences de
génie pour qu'on essaie de trouver
quelque chose qui est entre de bonnes
mains nues marché qu'ils ont approuvé
quatre ans et six propositions 2009
bon bah écoute on avait tout bien tout
bien lu quoi fragile récolter des dons
pour offrir des échecs à des hôpitaux
mais dit pas envie que ce soit dans les
échecs perso après pourquoi pas mais
après ça peut être pas pour refaire des
échecs derrière juste pour aider
directement
ouais
bon là je sais pas je pense à ceux
signés donc s'être une heure de jeu
aujourd'hui vous êtes il regarde le
sketch de jérémy ferrari a donné déjà vu
ça fait peur donc
raf ont retrouvé une bonne idée nulle
officiel un truc fauqué ben écoute ce
qui était prévu en fait du coup ok
petite surprise en ouverture maxima bas
bien réagi s'est pas laissé déborder par
ça et il a fait nul très facilement
voilà qu'on finalement peut être rien
d'autre à dire non il n'y a rien d'autre
à dire
on clôt la discussion avec les gens pour
pas finir
non mais c'est vrai qu'on avait la
première page mais là malheureusement
j'ai envie de te dire que peut-on y
faire
voilà c'est fini on va dire pin up a
passé une heure sur navarin iacono non
non non mais juste c'est pour ça que je
prends juste deux secondes pour répondre
oui non non ça c'est sûr qu'au fond ils
ont ils ont ils ont des idées
enfin voilà ce serait une bonne idée
pour le pour le 20 juillet mais c'est
dans les échecs je sais pas si vous
connaissez
d'ailleurs si vous avez le cas ce sera
intéressant de voir un joueur de haut
niveau qui a déjà fait quelque chose
parce que c'est vrai que dans les autres
disciplines les exemples on peut les
trouver assez facilement et dans les
échecs
parce que tu vois tu as comme ils ont
fait des trucs mais après c'était pour
aider les échecs féminin pour pour aider
meilleur et l'équipe allemande qui est
permis mais le choc
moi j'ai envie de faire un truc hors d
échec au bout d'un moment je sors les
échecs il ya déjà bien associer fait ch
envie de se dire il ya déjà beaucoup de
choses qui sont faites et c'est pour
essayer de faire pour donner à des gens
qui ont vraiment vraiment besoin quoi
pas georges meyer le club de clamart
fait des parties de chacun et aideront
oui je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de clubs
qui font des trucs pour les téléthons
pour le téléthon et bravo à eux du coup
nul partout et benny blanco dans toutes
les parties qui nous intéresse c'est
toutes les parties qui sont décisives ya
une vraie mais bien juste pour le coup
ou prochain tour des stades sur les
autres donc il est nul de saône une de
mainxe navarra yacou auxquels s'ajouent
spéciale le message ou et oui car yakine
ça joue aussi appel trop rapide entre
nous
je serai très bien dans pop corn ray
faut que j'aie il faut que j'écrive à
domingo d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de le
faire beaucoup de choses à faire en ce
moment et ils disent que oui et après il
ya eu des streamer ou quoi des petits
streamer qui ont fait des trucs je
parlais vraiment des gens connus je
parle pas des des individus ni des
petits clubs acquis à qui je dis bravo
d'air du coup que sauf un bah on va on
va dire au revoir mais je pense pas
qu'on fasse de résumer aujourd'hui
femmes non voilées d'accord à une fois
oui mais deux fois non mais on se
retrouve demain 14h donc pour les
parties rapides pour kruger et du
spectacle dont on aura une réponse
définitive
et puis on vous fera un résumé donc
demain sur les parties rapides quoi aya
gaspacho t car la scène montre carrée
contre guy ribes pour conclure à 6 mais
je sais pas ça a paru tellement bizarre
comme truc j'ai pas compris la finalité
de réduite et contre le racisme en
faisant jouer les noirs en premier moi
j'ai jamais pris les pièces blanches le
temps les gens blancs et pièces noires
pourtant jean noir enfin ça va peut être
que les verts c'est pareil en fait
pincer juste de couleur vous je les ai
marqué et puis enfin faut pas confondre
les pions quoi j'ai pas j'ai pas trop
compris le délire à part faire de la pub
ça m'a pas paru être un truc
edit je dis pas que c'est bien oui mais
ça m'a passé quelque chose mais ça n'a
pas paru être battue à nadal quand il y
avait des problèmes à majorque y va bon
on pourrait prendre d'autres exemples
mais tu vois vraiment un truc très
concret là j'ai pas trop compris face et
la méfiance mike favre on se fie m'ont
fait jouer un coup au noir affamé mais
on a lutté contre le racisme ça me
paraît un peu c'est justement le genre
de choses que je voudrais éviter de
faire vrai que ce soit pas de la com que
ce soit un vrai truc en fait y'a ivo
karlovic me demande si j'accepte tout à
fait sauter près de six heures ce soir
qu'ils veulent ce qui fit devenons
jamais je n'accepte aucune défaite du fc
ce samedi vers l'univers ne sera pas de
mon fait
après juste avait peut-être une petite
plante qui tu es mais juste pour dire ça
n'est peut-être d'un bon sentiment un
truc de car hassan qui rit je sais pas
mais juste ça m'a pas ça m'a pas
fracassé en termes de tu vois tu te dis
ouais pareil c'est pas à nadal qui nous
indique j'ai pris une leçon de ville
leino ont commencé j'ai pris une leçon
de vie wii fit sa trousse 0 face bah si
ça te coûte le marketing et tout ça mais
tu vois c'est un peu non mais après tu
peux faire ça te coûte de ton temps
c'est déjà toujours non mais après c'est
peut-être bien enfin je sais j'en sais
rien mais ça enfin c'est pas un truc qui
m'a personnellement m'a touché c'est
plus sa voix la petite cuve en secret
j'attends une deux bah oui je baille les
rugbymans japonais régler un canadien
qui ont aidé les japonais à des billets
à prix le typhon fais pas c'est ça le
vrai truc quoi c'est beaucoup quoi
s'attendre à les aider à des ordres à
l'aîné l'option marée noire non c'est
quand même le truc c'est un truc qui me
touchent pas relancer les gens qui vont
qui vont enlever sur les plages le
plastique etc
l'année démarre et non à toute
l'économie ouais mais même les gens qui
vont oui oui et même au delà des gens
qui vont juste juste nettoyées etc
c'est c'est cool mais d'un autre côté je
me dis
le problème devrait être réglé plus haut
il devrait juste hier moins d'emballage
on tape sur la gueule de ceux qu'il a
des emballages aussi de c'est autre
chose
dans moins qu'il est ce qui fait son
pique-niqué sous les trucs dégueulasses
bout d'un bateau qui dégazent on meurt
bronche pas déjà tu tue-le tue-le tue-le
force à regarder des échecs des parties
longues à 34 voilà ça ça t'apprendra
dégâts elle fait très attention je
devais de passer les parties du grand
prix fidh non-stop
tu vas plus recommencer là ça va tu
coules le bateau exactement ce que je
pense à quoi
il faut prioriser la baisse des
émissions co2 ouais y'a aussi oui les
gens qui enlève il ya réussi les gens
qui essayent tue c'est d'inventer des
technologies pour enlever les plastiques
qui sont déjà en mer ça c'est carrément
cool no spam
pour l'heure du vin non je veux dire
pour les chasser d'autres exigeant mais
c'est aussi essaye de faire à oui tu
veux dire oui
l'évident fr sorte quand chaise comme
s'il vous plaît ils sont déjà sortis gst
dar k il faut juste moi tu match à ce
point comme en français alors quand tu
te bats tu vas dans paramètres et humer
français note du meet you sorti gagnant
0 but de la main et ouais mais on va se
prendre la barre son cousin omar
vraiment avoir vraiment de la tête du
pied
en tout cas n'hésitez pas sur les
discordes à écrire là dessus ça peut
être intéressant pour essayer de voir ce
qui est faisable
ouais trop des idées pour le 20 juillet
et puis tu te trouves qu'il est aussi du
coup ouais non le téléthon après faut
enfin il ya des gens qui bossent dans
ces choses là où qui connaissent un peu
n'hésitez pas à écrire histoire
d'essayer de faire quelque chose de
vraiment bien et tu vas pas à pas que ce
soir on a donné une association bravo
hein c'est pas l'objectif en fait ce
serait pas l'objectif du tout c'est
vraiment faire quelque chose pour pour
des gens bien et utile pas que ce soit
pas que ce soit du n'importe quoi bon
bah du coup merci à tous et je vous dis
on vous dit à demain fab a les mains
parce qu'une bonne un bon dimanche en
fait et demain en route pour la qualif
quoi lundi décisif
ciao ciao